bonsoir voila merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france le royaume uni qui
reconnaît vouloir revenir sur certains
engagements en violation du droit
international s'expose à de graves
conséquences de la part de bruxelles
quelle est la stratégie britannique
encore un coup de bluff est la part de
boris johnson je pense que c'est une
tentative de d'exercer une pression
maximale comme dirait l'autre prenait
des cours et les sanctions mais je pense
que c'est dans cet état d'esprit que m
il est juste de la sorte mais ça ne veut
pas dire que je vois pas parce qu'un
coup de bluff voudrait dire que on ne
n'étais pas vraiment prête à donner
suite qu'il n'y avait rien derrière
ici il est possible que le but du
gouvernement sur cette disposition
précise qu' et qui apparemment figurant
dans un projet de loi être présenté
demain je pense que c'est l'intention
réelle de de faire passer cette
disposition je suppose et en ce qui
concerne l'éventualité d'une homme d'un
absence d'accord donc une séparation à
la fin de la période de transition qui
se termine le 31 12
je crois que boris johnson d'une part
est réellement prêts à à accepter ce
résultat si les choses se termine ainsi
mais que d'autre part il vend au vrai
très sérieusement pour parvenir à un
accord et il il suppose que ça se fera
dans la dernière ligne droite
en tout cas il a l'air de dire que voilà
il menace de quitter la table des
négociations à la mi ou comme c'est un
accord de libre échange mais n'était pas
trouvée
vous pensez vraiment paul thompson qu'il
ira jusqu'au bout il l'air de dire que
le no deal finalement c'est pas si mal
pour les britanniques mais enfin qu'en
pensent les principaux intéressés au
sein de votre population britannique si
c'est à vous que vous faites allusion
les avis sont sont variés comme ça
depuis le début du sag âme du break site
encore une fois je pense que il vise un
deal mais il faut regarder à ce qu'ils
se parlent de l'autre côté de la table
de négociation avec eux la position de
l'union européenne des 27 est quand même
à rigide sur des sujets absolument
fondamentaux par exemple exigé doigt me
dit qu ils doivent simplement s'aligner
sur sauver règles européennes de façon
assez générale alors que chacun sait que
tout le but du break site était de
revenir à plus de contrôle sur sur ses
choix politiques restaient buté sur
cette position pour moi est vraiment là
pour le coup totalement irréaliste et je
suppose que les l'union européenne
prévoit déjà de de revenir en arrière
dans une certaine mesure toute la
question de savoir ce qu'elle proposera
comme comme compromis de même prétendre
que dans les zones de pêche du royaume
uni tout doit continuer comme avant
alors que ce sont des eaux territoriales
du royaume uni est assez surprenant pour
moi donc bon restaurant ce jeu jeu mais
j'imagine très fortement se dit qu il a
enfin saint michel barnier qui a tam
assez obtus qui refuse de bouger sur des
soins absolument fondamentaux et que le
sang de lui leur coeur
le choix que de d'être aussi difficile
tout en espérant que encore une fois
dans la dernière ligne droite les grands
décideurs derniers départs un des grands
décideurs à se concerteront à manama
quand on fait partie des grands
décideurs et lui par exemple attaquant
qui est intelligent pragmatique qui
attache beaucoup d'importance à des
relations banny constructive avec le
voyage n'est pas le fruit tant qu'homme
et tout est pas on n'a pas perdu
merci beaucoup par thomson vice
président du parti conservateur
britannique en france d'avoir été avec
nous